okay so the Mandalorian season 3 is now
at an end and whether we got a lot of
questions answered in it we discovered
what moff Gideon's true plan was and
that was to clone Gus Fring so he could
once mobile
that was to create clones as part of a
secret mission started all the way back
in season one try this video we're going
to be going through what the moth was
actually doing what he wanted to achieve
and all of the steps that he took to get
there there's also a big theater
people are doing over his seeming demise
in the entry and I want to talk about
How likely I think it is that he's gonna
return if you enjoy the video please hit
the thumbs up button and also don't
forget to subscribe a breakdown take
this almost every day by the way huge
thank you for clicking this now let's
get them off Gideon's plan a Gideon's
plan is summing up against all the way
back in season 1 episode 1 using his
puppet declined Gideon ended up hiring
bounty hunters to gun retrieve a
creature known as the asset knowing what
we know about Keller and Beck I'm
guessing that after he rescued grogu
that he hid him throughout the Galaxy
and his potential death may have led
them after seeing an opening to get the
child now from what we know the end of
the season this was for a specific
reason that involved the force who knows
the moth may have even been after Becca
Point as I doubt he would have been too
choosy over who this Jedi was whether
coloring can obviously put up a fight
whereas the young Roku wouldn't be able
to though we know very little about his
species the others that we've met in
Yoda and yaddle have given things away
about how powerful they actually are
when George Lucas went over them he said
that these creatures were very much one
with nature and this is how they were
able to tap into the force on the level
that they do so you can see why gragu
would be a prime target but the
ambitious moth now the next part of the
plan involves the dark Troopers which we
see Gideon using throughout season two
these are advanced battle droids that we
saw him using throughout the series and
up until this point there had been three
versions of them firstly there was the
phase one Dark Trooper which was similar
to your typical Droid fighter phase two
build up from this with a third phase
being the bulky version that we see in
season 2. Gideon study this technology
and saw a way to put it into others
which allowed him to evolve the Dark
Trooper to become far more effective I
have created the next generation Dark
Trooper suit forged from bescar and the
most impressive Improvement
is that it has me droids though useful
lack the instincts that living soldiers
have and they're less able to improvise
droids are also unable to use the force
which takes us into the next part of the
plan for decades now there's been those
trying to see if there were ways to
create clones that could wield the force
and the Imperials poured a tune of
resources and effort into this the
cloners on Camino had technology that
the Empire ended up taking and then
characters like Dr Pershing were tasked
with making it work in the case of
Gideon we never saw if he made a
breakthrough but we do know that somehow
Palpatine returned eventually so the
groundwork wasn't completely wasted oh
now that Gideon also had his side set on
Mandalore and this was for primarily its
best score best goes in near
indestructible material that has the
capability to block Blaster bolts and
it's also capable of repelling
lightsabers at the end of season 2
Gideon saw first and there was dog
troopers were completely demolished by
Luke Skywalker unless you realized that
he needed a way to be able to counter
this if you wish to take over that's
where Mandalore came men and he planted
the planet for its best God to use it as
an armor which would help against any
foe he could encounter anyway in total
Gideon basically wanted to create the
perfect Soldier officer Imperial and
basically persons strong enough to rule
the entire galaxy his plan was to create
clones that had the ability to use the
full Sunny then outfit these with Dark
Trooper technology all wrapped up in a
suit of pescore since the Clones are
based on him they'd have his instincts
in mind State and we saw in the case of
the clown Troopers how similar they were
to Django fair when it came to fighting
you've ever played the Star Wars Bounty
Hunter game on the PlayStation 2 and you
know Chango completed a mission for
Dooku that involved taking down a dark
Jedi which proved that he was gonna be
the perfect template for the Clones so
Gideon's very much attempting to use
himself as a base because in his eyes
he's the perfect person to run a math
Empire anyway I also have a theory that
Gideon was very much trying to replace
the shadow Council and due to the
infighting in the group he didn't want
to rely on them to run things if the
Imperials got back in power though it's
not really touched upon in the show
there was a lot of division amongst the
shadow cancel with him all being out for
their own ends the person who created
the council even planned to bring them
all together to kill them at the Battle
of jakku so you very much have the idea
that they can't be trusted not even by
their own members therefore Gideon's
going with the idea that if you want
something done right you have to do it
yourself and this is why he's chosen
himself as a template to take over
everything about Gideon would ever
reveal that he's actually using clones
and thus all the Deeds carried out by
them would be attributed to one person
say Gideon centered his clones through
love of several planets you'd very much
get the idea that Gideon was almost
Godlike and someone that could
single-handedly control the entire
galaxy I can't imagine how demoralizing
it would be to believe that you'd kill
them and then find out there were rumors
of him operating out in the Galaxy if he
came face to face with him after
seemingly destroying him it would
demoralize you so much and you can
definitely see how this would be an
advantage to him now because there's
many people believe that Gideon might
actually still be alive somewhere after
the events of the finale there's lots of
theories about how he had a mustache in
the first two seasons and then didn't in
season three and this is something the
Clones themselves shared as well it's
basically mustache with lots of theories
online saying that this proves that the
Gideon that dies is a clone but I'm not
so sure Disney do tend to keep things
pretty simple and I don't know how many
times now there's been fan theories
about there being something else going
on in these shows that turns out to be
untrue everything outside of Loki seems
to end up being pretty straightforward
and I think that's also going to be the
case here too the fact is the Gideon we
encounter here isn't a force wielder
either which was the main point in
creating the Clones in the first place a
Gideon may not have managed to hit the
point where he could put the force into
his clones yet but I do kind of hope
this is the last we've seen of him a guy
always seems to be shoehorned in at the
end of the season so it at least has a
villain but when he's been beaten three
times the threat of him's really
diminished I hope that we get other
villains in the upcoming chapters and
with a shadow Council and thrawn now
being confirmed I think that they're the
right way to take things and there's
also what was going on with Dr Pershing
who in hindsight we know was likely part
of Gideon's plans tempted by a lion king
she was able to torture him and it's
possible that he may have been taken out
that his cloning knowledge couldn't be
used by others if Gideon is the only one
capable of doing it then in the end he's
the one who holds all the cots you can
kind of see the overall plan in the
season and though I'm not sure if it
paid everything off it does kind of
bring things full circle from that first
episode all in all this Henry does feel
like it could be the final episode in
the entire show and though we've got
lots of things involving the characters
coming down the line we now at least
have answers to what exactly is going on
I'd of course love to hear your thoughts
on the plan this season and whether you
think this series delivered or not
comment below and let me know and huge
thank you for rocking with us through
our Mandalorian coverage we will be back
for Ahsoka in August so make sure you
stay locked into land for weekly
breakdowns on the series now we are also
running a competition right now and
giving away the quantumania steelbook to
three subscribers on the 15th of May all
you have to do to be on the chance of
winning is to like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
comment below with your thoughts on the
series you pick the comments at random
on the 15 then the winners of the last
one are on screen right now so that's
you then message me on Twitter at heavy
spoilers huge thank you again for
rocking with me I hope you've enjoyed
our coverage and yeah I'll see you on
the next one you take care yourself
peace
[Music]